Instructor: Proxies
allow you to overwrite the
default behavior for many of an
object's default operations.
What I mean by that is, an
object you can get things, you
can set things, you can check if
it has an item, you can delete a
property. There's a whole
bunch of methods that come along
with a default object. What if
you wanted to overwrite these?
We've looked previously at
custom setters and getters,
which are actually not part of
the ES6, but what if you wanted
to overwrite absolutely
everything, or what if you
wanted to overwrite some of the
other properties in an object?
That's what proxies do. They
allow you to overwrite the
default behavior of an operation
on an object. To explain
that, let's take a look here.
Let's say we have a person that
is equal to, let's say name is
Wes, and age is 100. When I get
the name, let's say I wanted to
return something other than Wes.
What we can do is create a proxy
for that object. We'll say const
person proxy = new proxy.
Now, a proxy it takes two things.
First it takes a target, which
is, what object would you like
to proxy? We'll give it the
person. Then the second is
something called the handler,
and the handler is where you
specify all of the operations
which you wish to rewrite. That
is an object inside of there.
I'm going to bring you over to
the MDN docs for Proxy right
here. When you want to overwrite
one of the default operation,
those things are called traps.
Essentially what it does is it
sits between you and the object.
If I was to say, person
proxy.name = Wesley, what I'm
doing there is I'm setting the
property of name on this person
proxy here. What I want to do is
trap that from happening. I sort
of want to go in the middle and
implement my own logic for when
I want to set it. Here is
all the methods that you can
actually trap each other. This
thing is called a handler, and
each thing inside of the handler
is called a trap. I can trap a
get, a set, a delete, and apply
a contract. There's a whole
bunch of them that we can go
through, and you can look
through here, but let's do the
very basics of a .get. In here,
what I'm going to do is define a
get. This is just a regular
object with methods on it, so I
can use our shorthand here. When
you get it, you get the target,
and you get the name that the
person is requesting, and from
that, we can just do a console.
log. Someone is asking for
target and name. Let's take a
look at what that does here,
person proxy that's R.
You can think of this just as a
regular old object, and then I
call .name on it. We'll see,
someone is asking for, it gives
me the entire object as well as
the name or the key. Sometimes
people will call it, of it.
What could we do there? We could
just return nah, and maybe some
fun emojis. Let's see what we
got here. Germany. Now when I
ask for person proxy.name, we
get "nah" back, right?
We've sort of jumped in the
middle of that get, and hijacked
it, and returned our own.
Obviously, that's not what you
want to do, but you can modify,
you can check if things are
meeting your standards, or you
can do something like return
target name. That would just
bring us what we're actually
looking for. Console.log out.
Wesley. But you could do
something like .toUpperCase,
assuming that you're always
going to have a string, and then
I return it. It always returns
me upper case. That's really
helpful for a variety of reasons.
We're going to look at a whole
bunch of examples, but let's
quickly do another example of
when you might want to use
another trap, let's say a set.
Something that might happen
where you are setting, and
there's a whole bunch of white
space in the string that you're
setting. You have a target
and a name. Then we could say if...
Oh, and then we also get passed
the value that the person is
sending it. If the type of value
is equal to a string,
then what we want to do is say
target name = value.trim.
Now if I go to this person proxy,
and I try to set something new,
like cool = oh yeah, and a whole
bunch of white space in there,
it shows us that, but if we take
a look at our person proxy,
you'll see that we now have cool
is oh yeah. It's been trimmed as
we then brought it in. We can
also store like toUpperCase, and
then maybe we can concatenate on
some scissors because it was
trimmed. Just do something silly
like that. Person proxy.Wes = I
love Wes, lots of space on the
end there. Now if we take a look
at person proxy.Wes, it should
give us trimmed, upper cased,
and tacked on with an actual
scissors. Again, with a
proxy you can jump in-between
and overwrite the default
operations. You notice that I'm
not using any special methods,
I'm not using any special
functions here to set those
things. I'm simply just using
the object as I normally would.
Then the custom logic, which is
our handler, and the traps, will
take over. If you do not
specify one of these traps that
we have here, obviously there's
a whole bunch of them, the
default for the object will take
over.